musique john baez chanteuse ne peut se
dissocier de john baez militante et ça
depuis les années 60
ces premiers combats les massacres au
vietnam mais aussi les droits civiques
au côté de martin luther king et à
chaque fois sa guitare ses paroles et sa
voix accompagne sa lutte
john baez et l'icône de la chanson
militante mais elle agit aussi contre la
guerre au vietnam
elle participe à de nombreuses marches
pacifiques elle
arrêté deux fois et son mari de l'époque
sera envoyé en prison pour avoir refusé
de rejoindre l'armée américaine au
vietnam john baez a chanté à hanoi
alors que la ville est sous les bombes
quelques mois après elle raconte aussi
un extrait de la chanson qui m'a donné
le plus grand courage
hanoi sous les bombes pourtant je ne
pouvais contrôler mes genoux qui
tremblaient tout mon corps trembler le
seul moyen de dominer ma peur c'était de
chanter en dépit des bons
un single et nouba n'est qu'un mirage
ce qui provoque et qui porte au quai
moting au tout fric
les années passent et la chanteuse ne
change pas de philosophie elle milite en
faveur des droits de l'homme une lutte
pacifique qui l'amène au cambodge pour
stopper les massacres mais aussi en
amérique latine où elle sera privée de
concerts dans les années 80 elle fonde
sa propre association pour lutter en
faveur des droits de l'homme un
sacerdoce qui étonne les journalistes si
j'étais découragée de toutes les
défaites que nous avons subies je
n'aurai plus qu'à me suicider encore
aujourd'hui à 77 ans john baez reste une
chanteuse militante
car elle l'expliqué dans les années 60
c'est son job
[Musique]